[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin schönen guten Abend
Wintersport und Handballspieler mit dir
Christin in 15 Minuten schönen guten
Abend und wir beginnen die Sendung heute
mit dem Widerstand in lützerath wir sind
unsere Themen
Protest an der Abbruchkante Stopp den
Tagebau fordern Demonstranten in
lützerath einige geraten dabei mit der
Polizei aneinander
Diskussion um Nachfolge noch ist offen
ob und wann Verteidigungsministerin
Lambrecht zurücktritt die Union drängt
auf klare Verhältnisse
und das eigene Hotel auf Rädern seit
Corona boomt der Verkauf von Wohnmobilen
und vorerst ist kein Ende abzusehen
[Musik]
die Klimabewegung mobilisierte heute
noch mal um gegen die drohende
abbagerung von lützerat zu protestieren
und sprach von 35.000 Teilnehmern die
Polizei von 15.000 am Rande der
Demonstrationen auch vereinzelt
gewaltsame Auseinandersetzungen mit der
Polizei hunderte Aktivisten durchbrachen
Absperrungen und drangen weit in den
Tagebau bis zur Abbruchkante vor Peter
Böhmer berichtet
zu Hunderten stehen Demonstranten direkt
an der Abbruchkante des
Braunkohlebergbaus nachdem sie
Polizeiketten durchbrochen hatten
Lebensgefahr nach tagelangem Regen der
den Boden aufweicht sagt die Polizei
andere Protestierer versuchten in
Richtung des abgesperrten lützerats
vorzudringen es kam zu Scharmützeln mit
den Einsatzkräften
es gab eine kopierte versammlungsfläche
die sich hier im Nordwesten von lutzerat
befindet das wurde auch kooperiert mit
den Anmeldern und mehrere Tausend
Personen haben diese versammlungsfläche
verlassen standen damit auch nicht mehr
unter dem Schutz des versammlungsrechtes
und dann kam es zu den Szenen dass man
versucht der Polizei Kräfte hier zu
bedrängen zurückzudrängen in Richtung
lutzerat und in Richtung Tagebau konnte
die Kundgebung hatte friedlich begonnen
im kleinen keinen Berg nebenan das Dorf
war Startpunkt der Großdemonstration mit
laut Polizei 15000 Menschen laut der
Veranstalter deutlich mehr Protest gegen
die laufende Räumung des Nachbar
Örtchens lützerat um die Braunkohle
darunter zu verstromen
man muss die Gerichtsurteile anerkennen
aber man muss auch darauf hinweisen dass
jede Tonne weitere
kohleverbrennungen klimaschädlich ist
und uns wegbringt von dem 1,5 Grad Ziel
ich hoffe sehr dass die Polizei
Kennzeichen setzt eben es sich nicht
jetzt für kurzfristige Profite
einzusetzen sondern langfristig für
unsere Zukunft indem sie ein maratorium
vielleicht machen auf freiem Feld bei
strömendem Regen dann eine Kundgebung
auf der mehrere umweltgruppierungen eine
entschiedenere Klimapolitik forderten
auch die schwedische klimaaktivistin
Greta Thunberg war angereist
wird die Menschheit vor den Konsequenzen
des immer weiter so gewarnt
die Wissenschaft ist sehr klar die Kohle
muss im Boden bleiben
am Abend standen sich Polizei und
Demonstranten weiterhin angespannt
gegenüber Hundertschaften regelten
lützerath ab niemand soll mehr auf das
Gelände hinter den Bauzäunen kommen um
die Räumung zu verzögern
und wir schauen noch mal ins abgesperrte
lützerat dort ist Luther Becker für uns
Luther kann man schon eine Bilanz des
Tages ziehen was wird von den
Protestaktionen hängen bleiben
hängen bleiben wird ganz sicher dass
Zehntausende je nachdem ob man die
15.000 der Polizei oder die 35.000 als
Zahl der AktivistInnen AktivistInnen
nimmt hierher gekommen sind um noch
einmal zu zeigen was hier in lützerath
von protestierenden ja gefordert wurde
wird auch von einem nicht geringen Teil
der Bevölkerung gefordert obwohl es den
politischen Konsens gibt in meinen
Eindruck ist auch dass es für die Grünen
nicht ganz einfach sein wird zu erklären
warum man wo man doch in der
Landesregierung hier in
Nordrhein-Westfalen und in der
Bundesregierung beteiligt ist diese
Räumung von diesen dieses Abbaggern von
lützerath hat nicht verhindern können
wir sehen das ist aber in lützerat auch
weiter gegen während die Proteste liefen
hinter mir sieht man eins der Gebäude in
dem sich noch vor 24 Stunden Aktivisten
verschanzt hatten das wird langsam
abgerissen und auch weiter hinten kann
man es vielleicht erkennen gibt es
einige Lichtkegel das ist der ganze
Kreis rund um nützrat der nun weiter
abgesperrt ist in einem Bereich wo
Aktivisten aus der Gruppe der
Demonstranten versucht haben nach
lützerath hineinzukommen nämlich direkt
an der Kante zum Tagebau da gab es auch
teils und Auseinandersetzungen bei denen
auch Wasserwerfer zum Einsatz kamen auch
Hundestaffeln zum Einsatz kam aber es
hat keiner aus den Reihen der
Demonstrierenden nach lützerath hinein
geschafft so weit die erste Bilanz und
jetzt bei diesem schlechten Wetter am
Abend wird die Situation auch deutlich
entspannter danke schön Lothar Becker
nach lützerath und wie es dort
weitergeht rund um diese Thematik auch
in unserer ZDF heute App verpassen Sie
nicht in einem live-block halten sie
dort auf dem Laufenden
sie wissen in der Energiekrise da soll
verflüssigt des Erdgas kurz LNG
ausbleibende Lieferungen aus Russland
ersetzen heute wurde das zweite Terminal
dafür in Deutschland eröffnet an vier
Standorten soll es diese Terminals geben
in Rekordzeit geplant auch gegen Kritik
von Anwohnern und Umweltschützern ein
staatliches in Wilhelmshaven läuft schon
heute kam ein privat finanziertes in
Lubmin dazu Susanne Seidel und eine
Stadtfeld berichten
die Neptun das erste privatfinanzierte
schwimmende lng-terminal Deutschlands im
Hafen von Lubmin von hier aus wird
Erdgas in die Pipeline gespeist die bis
vor kurzem noch russisches Gas über Nord
Stream 1 ins deutsche Netz brachte
Kanzler Olaf Scholz eröffnete es
zusammen mit Ministerpräsidentin Manuela
Schwesig
es war ein gutes Gefühl hier zu drehen
und die Gasleitung gewissermaßen mit
öffnen zu helfen und alles ist Teil
eines Plans mit dem wir sicherstellen
wollen dass Deutschland all das Gas was
es früher importiert hat importieren
kann ziel sei es unter anderem mit dem
Bau von lng-terminals Engpässe durch
fehlendes russisches Gas aufzufangen in
Lubmin bringen shuttletanker Flüssiggas
zum Terminal Bus wieder in seinen
gasförmigen Zustand gebracht wird ein
schnell realisiertes Projekt dank des
sogenannten LNG beschleunigungsgesetzes
dass wir beschleunigte Verfahren haben
dass wir in wenigen Monaten dieses
Projekt genehmigen konnten MV liefert MV
leistet seinen Beitrag für die
Energiesicherheit von Deutschland doch
es gibt auch Schattenseiten die Anwohner
beklagen sich über Dauerlärm und der
Naturschutzbund Deutschland sieht
Gefahren für das angrenzende
Vogelschutzgebiet durch diesen
Shuttleverkehr zu Störungen kommen kann
dass diese sensiblen Tier also
verscheucht werden und damit erheblich
beeinträchtigt
nun ist das zweite lng-terminal in
Deutschland in Betrieb 11 sollen es
insgesamt werden
kaum versuchte Verteidigungsministerin
Lamprecht Gäste an die jüngsten
panzerpannen zu erklären folgen kurz
danach ernste Hinweise auf ihren
Rücktritt ein Rücktritt den sie nach
Informationen der Süddeutschen Zeitung
kommende Woche offiziell machen wird es
ist ein sensibler Zeitpunkt nächste
Woche laden die USA zur Konferenz wo es
auch um kampfpanzerlieferungen an die
Ukraine gehen dürfte Frank Buchwald
einer hält immer Wache im Bendlerblock
die Verteidigungsministerin aber so
heißt es in Berlin hat längst den
geordneten Rückzug angetreten höchste
Zeit findet die Opposition sie ist von
Anfang an mit dieser Aufgabe überfordert
gewesen sie hatte offensichtlich auch
wenig innere Einstellung zur Bundeswehr
es wäre gut wenn das was jetzt seit
mehreren Stunden als Gerüchten durch die
Medien geht endgültig mit einer
Entscheidung des Bundeskanzlers
abgeschlossen wird der Kanzler jedoch
hält sich bedeckt Scholz heute in Lubmin
an der Ostsee erweitern flüssiggaster
Terminal ein zum Thema Lambrecht kein
Kommentar die Ministerin gilt schon
lange als angeschlagen 5000 Helme für
die Ukraine Flüge mit Sohn im
Hubschrauber zuletzt dann misslungenes
Video aus der Silvester Nacht
und damit verbunden waren für mich ganz
viele
besondere Eindrücke die ich gewinnen
konnte viele viele Begegnungen mit
interessanten
also ich glaube auch dass sie sehr
unglücklich agiert hat in ihrem Amt ich
muss persönlich sagen dass ich die
Anschaffung von bewaffneten thronen und
atomwaffenfähigen Kampfflugzeugen einige
skandalöser finde als das Silvester
Video auch wenn das ziemlich peinlich
war so richtig wohl gefühlt hat sich
Christine Lambrecht in ihrem Amt wohl
nie so wird der Rücktritt für die
Ministerin fast wie ein Befreiungsschlag
und in Berlin fragen sich viele wer ihr
nun nachfolgen könnte im
Verteidigungsministerium
Unruhe im politischen Berlin fragen wir
nach bei shakunta La benergy im
Hauptstadtstudio was bedeutet der
wahrscheinlich bevorstehende Rücktritt
Lamprechts für Bundesregierung und
Kanzler ja wenn es denn so kommt und
darauf deutet momentan vieles hin dann
muss das Kanzleramt jetzt mit Hochdruck
die Nachfolge auf diesem wichtigen
Posten Regeln und die Aufgabe ist etwas
komplizierter als Sie vielleicht auf den
ersten Blick scheint denn idealerweise
müsste eine Nachfolgerin oder eine
Nachfolger in diesem Amt zwei
Bedingungen zwei Voraussetzungen
erfüllen nämlich zum einen die
Fachkenntnis und die Durchsetzungskraft
mitbringen um Olaf Scholz versprochene
Zeiten wenn in der Sicherheitspolitik
umzusetzen und auch um Reformen in der
Bundeswehr umzusetzen die längst
überfällig sind und an denen schon viele
Vorgänger gescheitert sind und zum
zweiten sollte das
Geschlechterverhältnis im Kabinett
eigentlich nicht verändert werden Olaf
Scholz hat einmal versprochen dass er
das Kabinett 50 50 mit Männern und
Frauen besetzt jetzt ist dann die Frage
wird er wird er dabei bleiben oder macht
er bei einer dieser bei einem dieser
beiden Kriterien Abstriche wenn es bei
der Parität im Kabinett nicht bleiben
soll soll dann könnte auch ein Mann auf
diesen Posten Folgen ansonsten müsste
man eine Frau an einer anderen Stelle
setzen und dann gäbe es ein größeres
Studium im Kabinett also eine komplexe
Aufgabe fürs Kanzleramt danke und danach
für die Informationen aus Berlin also
bislang schweigt das Kanzleramt in der
Sache und auch damit schade man der
Bundeswehr kritisierte CDU-Chef märz und
zwar in Weimar dort hat sich die Partei
zur neujahrsklausur getroffen
hauptsächlich auch mit Hinblick auf vier
bevorstehende Landtagswahlen geht es um
einen schärferes Profil bei so wichtigen
Themen wie Wirtschaft Energie und
Klimaschutz mehr von winnie-
Friedrich Merz und sein Bundesvorstand
besteigen die Wartburg in Eisenach
Grundsätze erarbeiten zum Kurs der CDU
ein schönes Gruppenfoto das war der Plan
doch ein erster Entwurf vom
Grundsatzpapier hatte Unruhe verursacht
so die Meldung die CDU wolle den Bau
neuer Atomkraftwerke Prüfen der
Parteichef dementiert wir sprechen uns
nicht für den Neubau von Kernkraftwerken
aus wir sprechen uns dafür aus dass wir
ich lese es ihnen auch vor so wie wir es
wörtlich beschlossen haben wir
befürworten die Fortsetzung der
Forschung und Entwicklung der
Kernenergie der nächsten Generation die
CDU erklärt sie wolle vorurteilsfrei
alle Energiequellen prüfen
Klimaschutzziele sollen vor allem durch
technische Innovationen erreicht werden
wir wollen in der Energieversorgung
unseres Landes wirklich den Blick 360°
öffnen auf alle Möglichkeiten der
Energieerzeugung deutschland braucht in
den nächsten Jahren deutlich mehr
Energie vor allen Dingen mehr Strom und
wir sehen das was die Koalition in in
diesem Zusammenhang gegenwärtig tut als
überhaupt nicht ausreichend an
Redebedarf hatten einige über den
Talkshow-Auftritt ihres Parteichefs März
hatte arabischstämmige Jugendliche als
kleine Paschas bezeichnet Kritik daran
wurde Partei intern mehr geäußert als
öffentlich es ist richtig Dinge
anzusprechen ich glaube das bestreitet
auch niemand und es muss halt auch ein
bisschen auf das wie ankommen es geht
nicht um pauschales aburteilen aber es
geht auch nur darum pauschal die Augen
immer zu machen und sofort reflexhaft
jedem irgendwie Rassismus vorzuwerfen am
Ende geht es für alle ins Bauhaus Museum
in Weimar gucken was früher war und
heute wieder modern sein könnte in der
Opposition ist die CDU da politisch noch
auf der Suche
der Iran hat einen ehemaligen
Vize-Verteidigungsminister hingerichtet
der auch die britische
Staatsbürgerschaft hatte Ali Reza Akbari
war wegen angeblichen Geheimnisverrat
zum Tode verurteilt worden die
Anschuldigungen hatte er vehement
zurückgewiesen Großbritanniens
Premierminister sunex sprach von einem
grausamen und feigenakt eines
barbarischen Regimes und in einem
Gespräch mit Präsident selenski kündigte
der britische Premier an der Ukraine
Kampfpanzer vom Typ Challenger 2 zu
liefern sie sollen dabei helfen
russische Truppen zurückzudrängen um wie
viele Panzer ist genau geht es noch
unklar neben Panzern versprach
Großbritannien auch artillerie-systeme
für die Ukraine dort in der Ukraine ist
heute überall Luftalarm ausgerufen
worden Russland Griff zahlreiche
Regionen des Landes mit Raketen an
darunter die Hauptstadt Kiel in die
libro in der osteokraine wurde ein
großer Wohnblock zerstört mindestens
die Menschen kamen ums Leben 27 weitere
wurden verletzt darunter auch sechs
Kinder die Sicherheitskräfte suchen in
den Trümmern nach Überlebenden in
anderen Teilen des Landes zerstörten
Geschosse Einrichtungen der kritischen
Infrastruktur
nach der Explosion einer Gaspipeline in
Litauen wird ein technischer Defekt als
Ursache vermutet vor Ort seien Schäden
an einer Schweißnaht entdeckt worden
heißt es von der Betreiberfirma der
Pipeline durch die Rohre wird Gas nach
Lettland transportiert die Pipeline war
gestern Abend explodiert verletzt wurde
niemand
weiterhin starke Regenfälle in
Deutschland vor allem im Westen und in
der Mitte in Hessen NRW und
Rheinland-Pfalz kann es entlang der
Flüsse in den kommenden Stunden zu
weiteren Überflutungen kommen in Hessen
ist die Fulda schon an einigen Stellen
über die Ufer getreten da die Böden
wegen der Niederschläge bereits
gesättigt sind nehmen sie kein Wasser
mehr auf höhere Pegelstände werden unter
anderem auch an Mosel Ruhe Wupper und
Sieg erwartet
die corona-jahre brachten ja den
absoluten Boom aber auch jetzt liegt
Campingurlaub noch im Trend Beispiel
Wohnmobile wurden davon 2019 gut
53.000 zugelassen waren es 2022 mehr als
67000 ein Plus also von mehr als 20% für
den Einstieg in den Campingurlaub kann
aber auch der eigene PKW aufgerüstet
werden zeigt die Reisemesse CMT in
Stuttgart und Petra Otto da
was für ein Ansturm heute morgen bei der
CMT alles wieder fast wie früher Masken
ade jetzt Freiheit genießen und Urlaub
planen auch wenn dieses Jahr Energie und
Klimakrise dabei durchaus eine Rolle
spielen ich bin schon seit Jahren mit
dem Camper unterwegs und man fährt halt
langsamer und auch nicht mehr so weit
man fliegt auch
mal weg irgendwie so Ausnahme ich durfte
für immer jeden Tag
1200 Campingfahrzeuge können Messe
Besucher und Besucherin hier Probeliegen
und begutachten und obwohl die Preise in
die Höhe schießen auch dieses Jahr
wieder um 6 bis 8 %, ist die Nachfrage
ungebrochen doch es gibt
Lieferschwierigkeiten
gerade bei den Wohnmobilen also wo man
ja ein Auto ein Chassis Ihren Motor und
dergleichen braucht mit der
elektronischen Ausstattung da ist man
schon noch viele Zulieferer angewiesen
und da hapert es tatsächlich Wohnwagen
dagegen sind gut zu bekommen ein
Hingucker diese Winzlinge unter zwei
Quadratmeter bettküche Schrank alles
drin noch minimalistischer und noch
günstiger Dachzelte Camping wird
vielfältiger unkomplizierter auch
abenteuerlicher das Wohnmobil der
Zukunft es könnte wie dieses sein ein
altes Postauto recycelt zum E-Mobil
Motor raus Batterie rein und in alles
Holz doch nachhaltige Campingfahrzeuge
die sind noch die absolute Ausnahme
Christin und ich sind für mehr Platz auf
jeden Fall und wir machen jetzt Platz
für Erfolge im Wintersport sehr schöne
und die tun richtig gut zweiter
Podestplatz für die deutschen
Skispringer um Karl Geiger in dieser
Weltcup-Saison diesmal im Teamwettbewerb
Rang 3 in das in Zakopane hinter
Österreich und Gastgeber Polen endlich
wieder positive Stimmung bei den
deutschen Skispringern stark verbessert
präsentieren sich in Zakopane besonders
Markus eisenbichler mit einer Weite von
140 Metern im zweiten Durchgang und Karl
Geiger der im Finale erst nach 138 m
landet gemeinsam mit Youngster Philipp
Reimund und Andreas Weninger bedeuten
konstante Leistungen Platz 3 im
Teamspringen im Duell um den Sieg rettet
Stefan Kraft im Finale Durchgang einen
hauchdünnen Vorsprung für Österreich ins
Ziel dich dahinter werden die
favorisierten Polen beim Heimspiel
zweite
große Freude auch bei den deutschen
Biathletinnen in Ruhpolding Rang 2 in
der Staffel hinter dem Quartett aus
Norwegen und vor Italien
die deutsche Damenstaffel strahlte beim
Heimweltcup in Ruhpolding um die Wette
mit dem begeisterten Publikum in der
Chiemgau Arena nach Startläuferin Anna
Weidel sorgte Vanessa Vogt mit
fehlerfreien schießen für den Anschluss
an die Spitze bevor er Sophia Schneider
mit einer großartigen Schlussrunde als
dritte an Denise Herrmann übergab die
konnte sich gegen die Italienerin
Dorothea Wierer durchsetzen und sorgte
so nach den Männern gestern für den
nächsten Erfolg hinter dem jeweils weit
vorauslaufenden Team aus Norwegen du
musst immer am Ball bleiben immer an der
Sache bleiben und ja es gibt noch ein
paar Sachen zum verbessern und das
wollen wir natürlich schaffen die
Staffelwettbewerbe von Ruhpolding waren
eine rundum gelungene Generalprobe für
die Oberhofer Heim WM im Februar
und Wintersport gibt es auch im
Aktuellen Sportstudio von 23 Uhr an in
dem Deutschlands bester dartsspieler
Gabriele Clemens zu Gast ist der mit
seinem Halbfinale Einzug bei der WM in
London viele Überraschungen
erfolgreicher wm-einstieg für die
deutschen Hockeyspieler in Indien 3:0
gegen Außenseiter Japan am Dienstag
wartet mit Hilfe der heilige Belgien
allerdings eine weitaus größere
Herausforderung
endspielcharakter hat für die deutschen
Handballer bereits morgen deren zweite
WM-Partie gegen Serbien soll in
Kattowitz der Gruppensieg verbucht
werden Zuversicht bei Torhüter Andreas
Wolf dessen leichte Wadenzerrung die er
sich gestern in der Schlussphase beim
Auftakt Erfolge gegen Katha zugezogen
hatte sofort behandelt wurde und kein
Hindernis mehr sein soll klingt wahrlich
nach Entwarnung wichtiger Mann
gott sei dank vielen Dank danke schön
Christin in der Nacht weiter Dauerregen
aber Entspannung ist in Sicht mehr
Wetter gleich mit Christa Orden das
heute journal heute um 22 Uhr mit
Christian Sievers ihnen allen schönen
Dank schönen Samstagabend und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend mit diesem Tief gibt es auch
heute Nacht noch den Dauerregen und erst
morgen entspannt sich die Lage
allmählich dann wird es im Norden mit
Schauern aber nochmal stürmischer und
kühlere Luft fließt ein aber noch nicht
heute Nacht mit 10 bis 3 Grad morgen
früh ist das eine milde Januar Nacht und
eine regnerische im weststau der
Mittelgebirge gibt es noch einmal um 20
Liter pro Quadratmeter Regen im
Nordwesten da ist es allerdings schon
etwas trockener so dass wir morgen
Vormittag zwischen Ostsee und
Niederrhein auch etwas Sonne haben das
Regenband bringt dann noch größere
Summen im Schwarzwald und oberhalb von
500 Metern auch etwas Schnee nachmittags
zieht es sich an die Alpen zurück im
Norden und im Westen gibt es da neue
Regen oder Schnee Regenschauer auch mal
für einzelte kaltluftgewitter an der See
vor allem aber entwickelt sich im
Nordwesten ein starker Wind an der See
und in Schauern auch mit schweren
vereinzelt orkanartigen Böden die dann
nachmittags Ost-
mit fünf bis zwölf Grad aber das ändert
sich in der kommenden Woche bis Mittwoch
haben wir noch höchstens minus zwei bis
fünf Grad und oberhalb von 400 Metern
wird es doch im Bergland etwas
winterlicher mit Schnee tschüss